fanny vous avez créé un compte twitter
mon pays ne protège pas sauvons hashtag
sauvons nos enfants sur sur lequel dans
ce conte que vous avez publié un
enregistrement des menaces de mort nous
allons écouter un premier enregistrement
audio de votre ex conjoint qui vous
menace de vous mettre dans un puits
écoutez lundi pour mobile va changer
parce que tu t'es fait quoi mettre
quelqu'un dans 28 des ménages
moi je veux pas toucher et hagen légal
tiger
c'est un premier enregistrement il y en
aura trois autres savoir c'est vrai que
c'est quand vous écoutez ça fanny vous
du port vous avez vu sur la toile un
nouveau jet faut savoir que c'est c'est
audio la faim qui ont passé il date de
quand elles datent l'a2 entre eux le
divorce a été prononcé officiellement en
octobre 2018 le 15 octobre 2010 fort aux
torts exclusifs de mon ex mari ont été
reconnus et
pour me protéger on ne fait pas la
passation de français la jugeant qu'il y
a décidé ça de ne pas faire la passation
à mon domicile
mais à l'école de ma fille ou au moment
des vacances dans un point rencontre sur
toulouse okéi sophie récupère votre
fille alors sauf que il avait été
débouté de ma demande de confidentialité
de mon adresse donc il sait man 2 nous
semble et ses 6 ans signer mon arrêt
actuellement il connaît votre domicile
oui et il vient il à cheyrou il vient
chez moi il a fait une tentative
d'effraction
il vient régulièrement il a menacé il a
été agressif envers l'une de mes
voisines donc je n'ai plus de poigne à
ma porte je
je ne peux pas tout dire ici tout évoqué
mais je multiplie les stratégies parce
que j'ai peur je suis en suis en vie
j'ai peur qu'il tue ma fille aussi je
peux pas sortir de chez moi rentrer chez
moi parce que au rythme des mises en
famille vous a pas vu une protection non
non ils disposent les la police devait
et et revoilà pauli alors j'étais revoir
la police elle je tiens à préciser que
dans que ce soir j'ai pris la fuite a
oui avant ça j'ai pris la fuite à 800 km
pour le fuir donc c'est pour ça que je
dis que la justice a donné à signer mon
arrêt de mort parce que j'ai je suis
parti à 800 kilomètres parce que son
ordonnance de protection jeu
continuaient de menacer et la justice
n'avait pas été appliquée il n'a pas été
en prison il est bien passé pas
suffisamment de preuves
enfin voilà sauf que j'ai pas d'autre
ennemi fédé audio c'est quand même une
contre moi je comprends pas parce que on
a en a brand et les cas reconnaît on à
des audio qui matérialisait quand même
mon année les monarques dans les côtés
d'autres comme un safetic avec des
oignons puisse pas le mettre entre man
alors je n'ai pas et la renommée paris
20e et non seulement lui donne votre
adresse que pour ces menaces là nous
faut pour ces menaces alors j'ai de la
chance c'est que il me laisse les
menaces de mort sur la mezzanine appelle
mon numéro tf1 parce qu'il me
géolocalise mais sur la messagerie de ma
fille
alors il n'a jamais appelé ma fille sur
ce numéro là ils s'en servent pour me
nuire donc j'ai est un téléphone mais
les fichiers arrive sur la la la
plateforme enfin le l'opérateur et il
faut savoir que ces menaces là les
plaintes ont été classées sans suite
j'ai fait cinquante cinq plaintes
classées sans suite pour infraction pas
suffisamment qu'alors on va on va
écouter un deuxième audio il vous n'avez
vous menace là de nouveaux bruits d
écouter que le problème juste là à
partir de lundi cave story chat la
charité alors vivre la famille a
témoigné pour tu te feras bien brûlé et
quand je te lis bien brûlé non je trouve
que c'est terrible et je trouve que là
c'est l'ongle mort justement de du
grenelle en ce moment c'est à dire ces
femmes qui ne sont plus chez leurs
conjoints qui sont partis et sam et qui
sont encore sous emprise
mais chaque mot chaque phrase c'est
comme un coupeur qu'ils contrôlent notre
vie on est
parle de contrôle coercitive de nos vis
ma vie dépend de lima retrouver sur mon
lieu de travail en 2017
j'ai dû changer de travail donc faut
imaginer aussi que même là je suis dans
le marketing dans le marketing digital
donc je ne peux rien faire en mon nom
tout se passe par les réseaux sociaux
les vitrines alors on s'arrange avec
mais ma société
bon je ne travaille pas en mon nom au
fait je multiplie pour pas qu'ils me
retrouve